we have all seen sci-fi movies
showcasing travel to mars
and sometimes even colonization of mars
but in reality
if we want to make mars habitable
without constant life support
we have to embark on a long and
extremely difficult journey
of terraforming mars and one of elon
musk's radical ideas to accelerate this
process
is by literally nuking mars into earth
so how in the world did we get to such a
proposal
and would it actually work
[Music]
well starting off when we're looking at
terraforming a celestial body
it would be really helpful if the
original planet is already somewhat
similar
to the earth fortunately for us mars is
relatively similar to the earth
and it's right next to us as well but
this
doesn't necessarily mean that it's easy
to terraform mars
sure it seems like mars may have some
polar ice caps
it has similar elements and compounds in
its atmosphere like
oxygen and co2 and most importantly
we can actually stand on it unlike the
gas giants
some other nice similarities include its
rotation rate and its actual tilt
a day on mars or a soul is only 24 hours
and 37 minutes
so just slightly longer than the earth
and mars's tilt of 24 degrees
is very similar to earth's 23.5 degrees
meaning that they see relatively similar
seasonal shifts
despite these favorable features there
are some large hindrances
for instance mars atmosphere is less
than one percent as thick as
earth's atmosphere and only 0.2 percent
of their already very thin atmosphere
is oxygen while 95.3 percent is carbon
dioxide
aside from this though the temperature
on mars is suitable in certain areas
where we have found temperatures as high
as 75 degrees fahrenheit
the average surface temperature on mars
is actually negative
81 degrees fahrenheit and temperatures
can drop below negative
100 degrees fahrenheit also the
gravitational pull on
mars is only one third of earth's
gravitational pull
but we can't really do much about that
right now
aside from that we would have to heat up
mars and change its atmospheric
composition
to support more oxygen and nitrogen
luckily
scientists predict that at one point in
earth's history
its atmosphere was also mostly co2
as a result we just had to figure out
how to replicate what naturally took
place
on earth considering this let's start
off by taking a look
at the less radical ideas before we dive
into nuking mars
the first idea is to take advantage of
extremely large orbital mirrors
and it's pretty straightforward
basically the idea suggests that we
should construct mirrors that are
hundreds of miles wide
and launch them to mars of course this
would be a logistical nightmare
but theoretically it might be possible
to construct
and launch such mirrors from space nasa
is currently developing their solar sail
which may be useful if we decide to go
through with this plan
anyways these 200 000 ton mirrors will
be placed a few hundred thousand miles
from the martian surface
and be used to reflect solar radiation
and energy
onto the martian surface we could place
these mirrors
at random places and they would
theoretically be effective
at raising the martian surface
temperature by a few degrees
at the selected location but the real
application for this idea
would be in conjunction with mars's
polar caps we would place several
of these gigantic mirrors near mars and
concentrate their reflections onto mars
polar caps
slowly this would not only melt the eyes
but also release co2 trapped within the
ice
as temperatures start to rise within the
polar caps of mars
this would lead to the release of
various greenhouse gases from the
martian surface
and as we all know greenhouse gases lead
to global warming
ironically mars terraforming plans
generally propose various ways to
artificially introduce global warming
to mars with that being said the second
plan is to straight up just pollute the
martian atmosphere
constructing and moving 100 mile long
mirrors would be
insanely hard so if we're going to
commit to moving so many materials to
mars
why not just build solar-powered
greenhouse-producing factories
on mars these factories would release
greenhouse
gases into the martian atmosphere to
thicken it up
and heat it up and they would also
convert co2
into oxygen for humans to eventually
breathe we have
inadvertently been very good at doing
this on earth
so we could just transition that success
i guess
lack of success to mars where it would
actually be helpful
after many many years it is expected
that though this won't completely
eliminate the need for breathing devices
it will eliminate the need for
pressurized suits moving on
we have an idea that rivals the
craziness of nuking mars
which is launching asteroids at mars
though the premise is no doubt quite
insane
this is actually much easier to
accomplish than the last two plans
we wouldn't have to transport millions
of pounds of supplies or construct large
factories
and mirrors rather we just have to strap
some super powerful rocket engines
onto a poor asteroid just taking a
stroll in the void of space
and send it down a suicide mission into
mars i mean
it seems pretty simple in theory but the
weight of what we would be doing
is quite heavy both literally and
figuratively anyways
the plan entails using nuclear thermal
rocket engines
that would move the given 10 billion ton
asteroid
at four kilometers per second towards
mars this would actually take about a
decade to do
but eventually it will be released onto
the martian surface
the impact will be so powerful that it
is expected to release
130 million megawatts of power
that's the same as 130 trillion watts of
power
which is enough to run the entirety of
everything we do on earth
for a full 10 years the impact will lead
to a rise in temperature of 3 degrees
celsius throughout the
entire planet of mars which would lead
to a trillion tons of water
being melted evidently given the
incomprehensible amount of energy
released by each of these asteroids
we would just need two handfuls of these
to cover 25
of the martian surface with water and
heat the atmosphere to a livable level
we may be able to accomplish all this
within just 50 years
after starting however the largest
drawback of this plan
is that the asteroid impacts would leave
mars inhabitable for centuries
though all of these plans may be
theoretically possible
nasa has confirmed that with today's
technology none of these ideas are
plausible
today this is likely to naturally change
within the next few hundred years
as we continue to advance or instead
we could implement an even crazier idea
that could further accelerate the
timeline
and that leads us into elon's plan of
nuking mars
elon musk has been teasing this idea
since 2015
and by his recent tweets it seems like
he is still relatively serious about it
considering the asteroid idea this
actually makes sense
the only difference is that the energy
release would originate from a nuclear
bomb
as opposed to an asteroid impacting the
martian surface
however as this is a nuclear bomb
instead of an asteroid
we would have more control over when it
explodes
in other words we don't have to wait
until the nuclear weapon hits the
surface before detonating it
elon musk describes that this consists
of a continuous stream
of very low fallout nuclear fusion
explosions
this way we won't disturb the martian
surface like the asteroids would
and we would be able to essentially
create artificial suns
within mars these nuclear bombs would be
targeted above mars power caps
which would of course lead them to melt
and heat up the planet
and musk claims that this is not risky
and that it would not make mars
radioactive
considering all of this nuki mars
actually
seemed like the most feasible solution
with the technology
that we currently have however one
serious criticism of the plan
is that it would take a mind-boggling
amount of nuclear explosions
according to the executive director of
ross cosmos which is a russian national
space agency
musk's plan would require a minimum of
000 nuclear warheads to put that in
perspective
we have a total of 14 000 nuclear
weapons today
but we did have 70 000 in 1986
so we are capable of creating 10 000
nuclear warheads
however that would be quite an endeavor
when this concern was raised to elon
musk
he simply responded by saying no problem
i guess that he just sees producing
nuclear warheads
as the simplest part of terraforming
mars
anyways at the end of the day whether
mirrors
factories asteroids or nukes the key to
terraforming mars
is figuring out the most effective way
to transform
mass into thermal energy this way we can
heat up mars and eventually establish
permanent bases
on mars without constant life support
currently
elon musk thinks that nuclear weapons
are the answer to this conundrum
but even if this idea does come to
fruition scientists expect that fully
terraforming mars will take a minimum
of a couple thousand years if not tens
of thousands of years
so that's way past our lifetimes anyways
however if we get the ball rolling
within our lifetimes
i'm sure we can make a respectable
contribution to the overall effort
do you guys think nuking mars is the
right way to go comment that down below
also if you guys think this video
explained the prominent ideas for
terraforming more as well
then make sure to drop a like and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one you